first of all thank you very much for
coming on today we're going to be
talking about derivation and
presentation storytelling with data
science in the business environment so
here's the deal here's all of us right
here right and we have this thought
bubble above our head and inside of our
head we've this beautiful picture but
how the heck are we going to tell people
about this beautiful picture I could say
mountains green trees but they're not
gonna stir to see this what's inside my
head what we're going to be talking
about today is getting this beautiful
picture and the audience that you're
trying to communicate with what you want
to do is you want to get this beautiful
picture inside of their heads right but
unfortunately there's communication
barriers this is the real world this is
your verbal talk this is your
presentation there's barriers getting
your picture inside of their head so
what we're going to be talking about
today is one how to find this beautiful
picture where does it come from in the
first place but then too how to remove
these communication barriers to get the
beautiful picture inside your audience's
head because if you're not careful
they're going to get some sketch looking
doodle mountain art green you know it's
not going to work out for them and
they're not going to get the message
that you want them to see all right
awesome so introduction so Who am I my
name is Greg cam rad and like Jared said
I was a part of galvanized data science
immersive i was there from april 2015 to
july 2015 so almost a year ago a little
more than a year ago and right now I'm
at Salesforce on their product data
science team and specifically within
their strategy and growth team and it's
been a great time what are we doing here
so I have a deep deep down belief that
we can all be data super man and data
super women I do and the only thing
that's stopping us from becoming these
data super people is a simple awareness
of the tools and process it's simply
knowing the program the process of doing
these cool data insights and
communicating them to your stakeholders
so to put this a little bit more
succinctly here's what I learned in
technical training here's what I learned
at galvanize here's what I learned at my
entire coding experience and then I took
that and here's what I've learned at
Salesforce here's what I learned on the
job and what we're going to go over
today is combining these two simply the
two puzzle pieces coming together
because what I found out immediately is
that the world is a lot different than
the technical training that's simply a
tool to get your message across to the
business stakeholders because run the
coolest algorithm you want at the end of
the day if it's not driving value then
that's simply all it it is a cool
algorithm alright so presentation to me
overview basically with this
presentation I'm telling you to take
this material use it as a guideline for
yourself alter it digest it and make it
work for your specific situation so one
of the lessons I want to say today is
whenever you see a presentation it's not
the source of truth it's a guideline for
you to take digest and make work for
your specific situation and throughout
this presentation we're going to have a
couple different will call them not key
points but notes and so we're going to
main topics in takeaways it'll be tips
and questions rhetorical questions
direct questions and additional goodies
and resources after this I'll have a
link for you guys you can download x2
material for presentation resources
everything scheduled we're in the
introduction right now we're going to
jump into a derivation portion and then
finally we'll jump into a presentation
portion so let's jump into it what is
data science data science is a lot of
things and over the course of my short
data science career I've learned that
data sign it's a marketing term is what
it is and what you need to understand
that there's a lot of words around it
but at its core saying you do data
science is like saying you do art so
what does that mean exactly you know to
your grandma or to your mom saying you
do art that's cute that's awesome to
like a real data scientist someone who's
doing it in production in the world
telling them you do data science I'll
say
you know cool cute that's awesome but
one of the Integrity's were going to get
from here is saying you do data science
it's like saying if you are and when I
think of data science what comes to mind
for me is turning insights into action
so really it's your the data scientist
is the vehicle between the data and
getting business value out of it and
then finally data science creates data
science products so this is when we're
talking about tools in production so
we're talking about Spotify his
recommendation system Pandora you know
Facebook's image recognition but then
ultimately data science is necessary for
companies to stay competitive in the
future now this is the first time that
we've talked about companies in data
science or using data science to drive
business value and I know what you must
be thinking you Greg I thought data
science was going to dataset IO
downloading the SF crime data set
opening up an eye Python notebook
importing SK learn preventing me prevent
presenting via matplotlib and writing
200 function line undocumented uncomment
uncommented code that you know nobody's
can be able to read on Gabe anyway a lot
that was data science true yes that's
usually what it looks like on between
you and your local machine but in the
real world that looks a little bit
different so the role data science in
business one easy maintain maintain a
competitive edge it's one of those
things where everybody's doing it
everybody's taking advantage of the new
tools and processes that we have to get
their competitive edge we're getting
into a world over Benton's we're a while
but simple stats aren't working in the
business world anymore that's where the
data scientist comes in that's where
this new computational power comes in
and finally the ultimate goal with data
science and business is to prescribe
actionable change so as a data scientist
our ultimate goal is to prescribe
actionable change which means you've
made an impact on either a product
roadmap or a business decision or you
helped a product manager you know with
the decision that they have but
ultimately the world is
different because you interpreted the
data a certain way and presented in a
certain way and obviously things you
complex that is where the data scientist
comes in because as we know there's
three parts of the data scientist it's a
technical aspect the math and stats
aspect and then finally the hardest part
is the business domain and experience
and understanding what the heck your
stakeholders want all right so now as a
general outline for how it data to data
scientists time is spent in the real
world I split up into three different
parts here first you have your data
quality prep planning and gathering
think of this is like the data
engineering aspect of it finally you
have your presentation and communication
part portion of it I mean do all the
cool stuff you want but if you're not
giving it to somebody else in a
digestible manner it's not going to go
anywhere and then finally a common
misconception is people think that the
third pillar would be algorithms and
things like that let's not get that
fancy it's its analytics is what it is
and when we talk about the analytics
portion what I found is that data
science it's only about a third of your
analytics portion so when I'm
interviewing people I'm doing phone
screens and I'm hearing all these things
people are always pitching to me Greg
I'm a data scientist on this good at
data science but there's so much more to
the job than doing some cool algorithm
all right now this is a very general
model if we split this up into the
different types of data scientists you
have your data engineers you have your
machine learning experts you have your
visualization people and then you also
have your analytics managers different
positions will have different thirds of
this bubble or of this distribution
different people will do more data
science than others in the algorithm
sensor whatever but the main key key
point here is we all have the same goal
no matter what kind of data scientist
you are and let me even abstract it even
further up than that these are all data
people you know I'm saying they take the
data and they're a medium to give
business value out of it so our goals is
a data scientist one we got to ramp up
quickly to get in the shoes of our
external stakeholder
well Greg external stakeholder the heck
is that it's somebody who needs to use
the data because in a business the data
scientists aren't the one managing the
products of the go-to-market they're not
the ones coming up with new features
necessarily there's exceptions obviously
but data scientists are used as a medium
for the data into the business value
next the the goal of data scientist is
to do data science through a business
lens so what that means is you're not
just going off and doing random forests
on some data set for the heck of it
because you're not getting paid to do
random forests on a data set for the
heck of it you're getting paid to get
business value out of the data so you
really have to optimize where your time
is and do trade-offs finally this is so
huge you have to communicate these
results effectively because it seems
like you have all the time in the world
to present to your external stakeholder
but in actuality you have their
attention for 5-10 minutes maybe 30
minutes for a meeting if you're not
communicating your results effectively
you're going to be in trouble because
they're not going to get your idea and
you're not going to complete your goal
that very end process of being a data
scientist and then finally I said it
once before but prescribing actionable
change we're going to go into what this
means but one of the key words here is
actionable it means somebody else can do
something with the data usually a
project manager a VP and exec they're
not going to sort through the data
that's what we're here for is data
people cool rhetorical question if you
think about what is your goal when you
start any job I mean really before you
start any job in the ever it's you want
to put value into the business and you
want to prescribe this action will
change you want to make an impact and
that's what we're going to learn how to
do is how to make an impact as a data
scientist so data science projects to
start laying out the outline for the
rest of the day will go into is briefly
but very roughly you have your
hypothesis or goal you have your data
and then you have the tool you're going
to be using against it what we learn a
lot in the in technical camp sir you
know you know the technical boot camp
is we're going to learn about the data
we're going to learn about the data
science toolkit that parts covered
that's good there's some very very good
resources out there for us to become
knowledgeable about these aspects what
we have a harder time with is this
hypothesis or goal and to formalize this
process a little bit more we look at the
data science you know project timeline
you know you acquire your data you prep
it this is where you clean it this is
where you cleanse it you analyze your
data and then you finally you act upon
your data splitting this up into two
different parts if you think about it we
have before we have our conclusions
which is on the left hand side we have
our conclusions and then we act upon our
conclusions right split this up into the
day we split this into two parts one is
the derivation portion of it so this is
doing data science but like I said
before you just do data science it's not
helping anybody out we have to present
this data science we have to present our
findings this is where the communication
aspect comes in all right put it one
more time like I said before you have
your ideas for a hypothesis in the
middle finally you get to your main
points or your takeaway or your
conclusions and finally you have your
communication I want you to notice that
I haven't said anything about an
algorithm or computational power or some
crazy data set that's 20 bajillion rose
or something like that it's because that
stuff doesn't matter really what matters
is you have the data and you get your
business inside out of it split this up
again derivation the part before you get
your main points this is doing the data
science and finally the part after you
do your data science this is the
presentation aspect of it it's a
derivation obtaining or developing
something from a source origin awesome
and presenting a matter of style in
which something is given offered or
displayed putting it one more time I
love this analogy we're going to go over
a couple now just that I love this one
is you have an arrow and if we split
this arrow and a half you have the
weight or the wood of the era and then
you have the part that drives the point
home you have the arrow partner there
guys these are to action for your sir we
have derivation before and so this is
the weight of your presentation this is
the content this is the material and
then finally you have your communication
aspect this is the presentation this is
the part that drives the point home so
the derivation is the good content the
presentation is your awesome delivery of
it will go into these main points I'm
not worried about them right now we'll
go into each one but for derivation we
have ramped up we have a feedback loop
we have prescribing axonal change for
presentation we have starting with main
points I love this one we have tuned
tone and abstraction I extra love this
one I'm really excited to go over that
and finally we have our preparation and
understanding common curveballs cool so
let's talk about derivation like I said
before finding our Mountain derivation
is how do you find your Mountain how do
you find your cool content how do you
find your material derivation is is
doing data science through a business
lines but on the exact flip side of that
as well it's doing business through a
data science lens and that's why data
scientist is so valuable because they
have two sides of the same coin a lot of
business people will be domain expert
domain experts they'll know the business
like the back of their hand data
scientists have a hard job because they
require both both the technical aspect
and the business aspect derivation three
men points let's talk about these
ramping up so this is when you get into
a new project or this is when you get
into a new company or a new industry or
anything like that and there's three
main parts ramping up there's your
overall business goals there is your
external stakeholders goals and then
finally there's your project goals
alright so when you talk about overall
business goals this is this is figuring
out how can you contribute to the
overall business and the overall the
entire scope of the business because a
good data scientists won't have a narrow
project scope they won't say this is my
project and then I'm all done because
this is all that's asked of me they'll
look at the entire holistic picture and
figure out how can they contribute to
the overall goal so the way that I like
to think about this is through a couple
examples here if I'm going to start at
lift
I'm not just going to go you know in to
lift HQ and sit there and look at the
data and not understand it if I'm going
to go into lift I need to get myself
ramped up with the business I need to
feel where the data is coming from so I
need to drive for lift I need to take an
uber I needed a lift ride you know lift
line I need to be a passenger for lift I
need to work try to recruit drivers and
so I know where the heck this is going
you see how we have the whole holistic
picture just for lift here imagine how
powerful that data scientists will be
rather than somebody just sitting in
front of an Excel document stitch fix I
need to subscribe to their clothes shoot
let me go to the warehouse let me
package up a few of these clothes and
let me see the entire process so that
you start to have a holistic view about
what the world looks like for that
particular company finally post nights I
need to order a burrito from the mission
when I'm sitting the north beach so I
could see how it goes I need to drive
for post mates and so I could see where
this data is coming from so now when I
have a column in my table and it says
rides completed I won't just know what
that means through text I'll feel what
that means imagine how powerful that
data scientist will be finally our next
you have your external stakeholders so
this is when your project comes around
it could be a project manager it could
be a VP it could be an exec but within
the company everybody has different
goals it's very very important for you
to understand what is the goal of the
person you're presenting to because once
you know that you can do your analysis
you can do your analysis with that in
mind and maybe even go a step further
because they might tell you what they
want but if you know what their overall
goal is you can contribute in such a
larger way and finally we're into
project goals so project goals usually
the way that goes is you know you have
your scope you have your project you
have a meeting and somebody says Greg
give me some data I'm trying to do this
cool sounds good but really what they
have is an overall main goal and so
there's a to get to this overall main
goal there might be five or six projects
that come along with it for example Greg
we're trying to figure out why users are
turning okay so
look at you know the days active for a
user and see if I could use the number
of days active they were in the previous
month to see if they're going to turn
cool but they're not really trying to
figure out how users are churning
they're trying to figure out how can we
get more users and we think users
turning ISM is one of the symptoms of it
so what you'll have here is you have a
whole bunch of different projects and
they'll all be sub-projects and they'll
all have sub goals the reason why you
guys are going to be such cool data
scientists is because when your goal
comes around and your project come
around because you did you're ramping up
you're going to be able to put your
project in terms of the main goal you're
not just going to stop at the scope but
you're going to understand what you're
being asked and you're going to do your
project with the overall main goal in
mind so yes usually how these
presentations goes you'll answer their
question cool and then right after that
you'll say well I know you're interested
about this too here's how it relates to
the larger picture because your external
stakeholder ninety ninety-five percent
of the time they have the bigger picture
in mind and they need help completing
the bigger picture but they're only
going to tell you a sub-portion of it
cool feedback loop this is all about not
doing too much work before you have to
if I ever start doing too much work and
it's unvalidated like I'm unsure if I
need to do it if I'm writing this big
long script and I'm not even sure if I
need to complete if I'm not even sure if
Mike stakeholders going to want it then
that's that's your starting off the
wrong way what you need to do here is
you need to find the signal in the data
so the way you find signal is through
validation with your external
stakeholders he even starts with a
hypothesis why do all the work by doing
it two hours worth of work in an eye
Python notebook to come to some just to
come to some conclusion if you can just
go to your stakeholder in the first
place and say hey I have this hypothesis
would it be valuable if I if I put in
the work and I found this out they might
say sure if they say they don't care
about that hypothesis and they really
would like to rescan good thing you
didn't put two hours of work into it you
know I'm saying so this is about getting
the feedback loop this call is
about testing the message here and
usually the way that I know that I found
signal in my projects is this last
bullet here is the signal answers so why
there's so many times and looking at
presentations and a slide will pop up
and set me to say i was thinking myself
so what okay so but so what though you
showed me this cool graph but so what
what am I supposed to take away from
this signal usually the data will look
like white noise this is how it usually
goes next you know out of this white
noise comes a couple clouds and then
finally has a data scientist when you
know you're on to something cool I know
you guys all know this feeling the
clouds they start to turn into little
something and there's a heart right
there because the heart feels good when
you find the data in it you know saying
i'm looking for a word to describe that
but so many times i've looked at a data
set and seeing something awesome and
it's like that is why my data scientist
right now because we just found out this
really cool thing and i cannot wait to
go present this so the feedback look
like i said you have this hypothesis
don't go put in room to work until you
know your hypothesis is validated I'm
not talking about finding out if it's
right or wrong I'm talking about if
anybody will care if you find out your
hypothesis because nobody cares and why
you doing in the first place then you're
going to go collect your data you're
going to work on your one goal that we
were talking about and then you're going
to go with that one goal you're going to
go test the message hey am I going the
right direction because the last thing
you want to spend two weeks on something
and how to have your external
stakeholder tell you that it they don't
really care too much about it cool next
we'll move on to prescribing action will
change your job isn't to show a graph is
to instill change action will change
what does it look like it looks like
when you have a product roadmap that
you're helping solve or layout and it
was set out one way but because of your
data insights you've literally changed
their roadmap because of these cool data
insights all right
and this is it action will change looks
like advising your stakeholders so a lot
of people when I talk to them they think
data science is just answering questions
and all these and all these small things
but once you get into advising that's
like the upper level upper level of data
meta pneus like you can cool predict
stuff but if you can advise the business
based off the data that's where you want
to be that's where the ultimate goal is
as a data scientist and like I said
before if you can't answer oh so what
about your insight of so what about your
bullet points so about your slide then
how does it help the goal and why should
anybody care about it I'm going to harp
on this a couple times here and we've
presented a couple of times your job
isn't to show a graph your job is to
guide a business decision a lot of
people they will just show a graph for
the heck of it and like cool it's pretty
sure seabourn matplotlib d3 sick but so
white so what about it and finally at
the end of your derivation you're going
to have your main points and the way
that this works is you're going to
finish with bullet points so if you
can't write down your main conclusions
in bullet points then it's going to be
too complicated to present to any of
your external stakeholders if you're
making a cool visualization a cool tool
sure like that one SF housing with the
blow-ups and the foreclosures and stuff
that's cool it's awesome it's visual but
in a business environment they don't
need something like that they need to
make a business decision here and what's
cool about finishing with both points is
you can't BS the results because after
each bullet point you look at you say so
what if you cancer so what about it then
you got to scrap that bullet point and
put it somewhere else so at the end of
your data science career at the end of
your data science presentation it's like
oh shoot I'm done it's awesome it's
great well no unfortunately or not
because you still have to present this
information you have your cool bullet
points but without the proper ship to
guide it into your stakeholders mind
it's not going to go anywhere it's going
to stay with you dude are we doing on
time
awesome now moving to the presentation
aspects and so now at this point we've
done our cool data science we have our
main points we have our external
stakeholders goal in mind and we're
going to knock it out the park but we
need to communicate that communicate it
to them somehow so like I said before
with bring it back to this original
analogy we're going to talk about how to
remove these barriers now this is the
presentation aspect of it when I say
presentation usually presentation of the
slides but if we abstract it all the way
up presentation isn't slides it's
getting my message into your ahead so
sometimes people do that through art
through a song through a speech through
slides they do it through video through
a lesson through tutorial they do it so
many ways abstract it up and realize
that i'm not saying presentation isn't
it has to be slides i'm talking about
getting something inside your external
stakeholders head so what does
presentation presentation is
communication bring a right around
communications presentation abstracting
it up getting inside what's in your head
to somebody else's head and what's
awesome about this is this is how these
two are connected derivation ends with
main points presentation starts with
your main points started I started some
main points you're the three points to
let's do one more Oh after this I forgot
to mention there's going to be a whole
bunch of resources you guys can take
home so i'll put a link up here you guys
can grab them there's a bunch of goodies
in here i'm excited to get over to you
so presentation starts with the main
points so your main points are your
bullet points and then the voiceovers
this is your these your subtle points
this is when you show either a graph or
a main point and then you have your
voice overs as an accessory to these
points like i said before it's it's easy
to spot the BS in your main points after
you get your derivation portion out of
the way that your data science portion
and finally this introduces a iterative
presentation style what i'm telling you
right now is you start any presentation
any visual endeavor with these main
points and you get an iterative
presentation style so like i said before
this email pitch
this is my pics to do this talk at this
conference I said hey here are the main
goals I didn't show any presentation any
slides anything I tested the message and
I said hey would this be a cool idea I
got a good response and they said yeah
sure let's do it so my presentation
started with this email pitch and next
thing you know then we start working on
the visuals because that's where all the
pats where all the work is put into when
I go about designing a presentation
start off with the main points again
these are the bulb points so if I were
to put this into like a building analogy
this is when you're doing your very
rough design outline you're very rub
blueprints test the message see if it's
working next we'll go into the more
detailed concept design this is when you
do your slide titles and you're
supporting bullet points see there's no
visuals here at all and there's no
graphs here at all after we're joggin
we're doing some walking so this is when
you started putting your graphics in
your theme but along each of these ways
you've tested your message with your
presentation so you know you're on the
right track you've validated with your
external stakeholder to make sure that
you're on the right way after you're
walking you're doing the cosmetics this
is your voice overs this is your
transitions this is your animations and
finally the last one was what i like to
call honey i shrunk the kids because
this means it made me think of that
scene when he's over the grass like
looking for everybody with the
microscope and going over at each
fine-tune point that's when you that's
when you do all the final touch-ups to
your presentation there so tuning tone
and abstraction this is my favorite part
so get ready abstraction this is getting
it to just the right level of detail
another analogy another metaphor here is
the pot isn't too hot the pot isn't too
cold but the presentation is just right
the level of abstraction is just right
Pablo Picasso he is a master at
abstraction we're gonna go into one of
his paintings here and we're going to
talk about what it means to abstract up
when you're talking about a data aspect
this is his bull series how many people
have seen as bowl series before we have
Linda [ __ ] cat with about seventy seven
of us what we have here is we have
that's eleven versions of the same Bowl
but they're at different levels of
abstraction what that means is is in
this first bowl at the top right there's
a lot of detail on there and it is a
bowl but there's a lot of small my new
details in there as you move down it
becomes a stick figure it's still a bowl
but it's at a different level of
abstraction let's put this into a data
aspect when you do your data project
this is where you sit because you know
all the data you're intimate with it you
know the columns you know the algorithms
you know the inner workings great your
boss is a little out of the details so
he's gonna be a little bit lower he's
gonna get that it's a bowl but he's not
going to be in the level of detail now
when you start presenting this to other
people you have your technical people
they still get a lot of the detail but
they're still going up on the
abstraction finally or next do you have
your department VP so imagine this is
the VP of analytics he gets what you're
doing but he doesn't need a lot details
he needs a bowl but he doesn't need the
details of the bowl he can only take on
so much next we have our execs these
guys are pretty these guys are really
high level up here and finally you guys
understand this but then you have one
more why now
then you have the public if you try
presenting any data to the public ever
you need to simplify it as much as
possible so the public's it's out here
at the very end so the main topic can
take away for this communicating
effectively is about finding the right
balance between information given and
abstraction so here you're not giving
much information but you're still
succinctly telling people that it is a
bowl and they get it but they don't need
all the detail let's put this into an
actual data problem here let's put this
into an actual data problem here so the
first level of abstraction oh you have
this matrix graph doesn't this graph
look cool first of all yeah but so what
how do you want somebody to digest that
nobody's going to be able to look at
that okay cool let's break it down a
little bit the interdependent
relationship between the five comical
variables is really cool it's like yeah
you have one graph but how the heck is
somebody supposed to digest that okay
let's break it down just a little bit
further let's abstract up let's still
show our bowl but let's not show as much
detail if you look carefully you can see
my point in this graph so you get it
you'd be very surprised as to how many
people show stuff like this it's
ridiculous all right let's break it down
even further let's abstract it a little
bit further up our kpi's have been
growing in a linear fashion for the past
four quarters all right so I'm starting
to get a little bit about what you're
trying to tell me cool if I'm trying to
tell you that our kpi's are growing do
the axes matter do the data points
matter i mean i'm really i'm not trying
to tell you that didn't februari was you
know 405 or whatever try and tell you
that we're up until the right let's
break it down even further so we've been
growing month over month due to these
three factors sweet we've been growing
due to these three factors and there's a
graph no axes because actually don't
matter the data points them out are cool
but then what I'm trying to tell you is
what i'm using this graph for is to send
a message to you
who says I have to show you a graph you
know I mean if we abstract this up even
further why don't we simplify it we're
growing here's why I mean you guys laugh
but what I'm trying to tell you what I'm
trying to help you make a business
decision I need to tell you that we're
growing and here's why and then there's
a thumbs up because we're casual it's
cool it's good the picture in instills a
light-hearted image in your head and
it's not so business e they remember
this stuff so we're growing there's the
main message here's why I didn't need a
graph to tell you that so we talked
about abstraction think about when
you're about to put in the graph it's
like okay cool but so what what are you
trying to really tell me don't so tone
is general character or attitude these
are the most polar tones I can think of
that's why they're up there spongebob
Bueller and your grandma so pictures in
voice I love putting pictures and I love
having a light-hearted tone with my
presentations because a lot of people
have this expectation about what tone
needs to be and i'll tell you right now
Tony needs to be whatever the heck you
want it to be it's your voice it's you
there's no business tone there's no
presentation time there's no data tone I
don't need to flash fancy words in front
of you what I love that I love this last
bullet point here your audience doesn't
need a two inch drill they need a
two-inch hole your audience doesn't need
a graph they need the insight from the
graph all right so picture is getting
the point across I love pictures and
presentations because they add a ton of
a motion to your presentation the first
one on the right it's this is a great
presentation from a galvanized employee
and it says a perfect storm of supply
and demand when talking about data
scientists she could have put you to put
that up against a blank slide but now we
have george clooney and i forget the
other hikers name in perfect storm and
they get the emotion it's things are
getting real it's getting crazy the next
one the kid it's just the beginning
where's the kid running to where is he
going to the beginning of what what's he
gonna do in life who's it going to
to be it inspires so much more than just
saying it's the beginning and finally
preparing the felt preparing the felt
someone's about to have a bad day and
you get that message because I'm showing
you a tanker about the tip all right
it's easy to do this you throw quick
dramatic picture you throw one line
maybe you throw up two lines and then
you throw up some dramatic text right
after that it's easy it's really not
that big a deal so keep in mind that
pictures are okay with data and they
help get the they help get the metaphor
across and you've seen here we've talked
about a lot of pictures here tone a
metaphors and analogies are great
because they attach your message that no
like they don't know your data message
but if you attach it to a concept
whether it be pictures or an analogy or
Picasso then it helps guide it into the
mind it helps them digest it a little
bit more so don't be afraid of metaphors
and analogies here we use this in the
real world leaky bucket easy new users
are going into a leaky bucket and turned
users are coming out it's a metaphor
it's analogy it helps my business
partner understand what the heck is
going on so when we talk about
presentation and anticipation of
curveballs there's a lot of things that
happen when you're on fly with the
presentation it could be it could be you
know you needing the practice and review
your slides you're showing your team
members of sandy to check this is the
feedback loop we're talking about here
and finally we're talking about these
common curveballs we have our time
pressures you're giving a presentation
the next thing you know there's two
minutes left you have your unexpected
questions you have your you have your
stats ready so people are always going
to ask us your questions you have your
stats they aren't in the presentation
but they're in your notes ready to go
and then finally the ultimate ultimate
way to get rid of any question is say
hey let's talk about this later because
you don't want to answer a question you
don't know in the presentation you said
it's talk about offline and part of what
your guys are going to get later is a
bunch of common resources and mechanics
these are slides I'm going to give you
guys right after this presentation will
leave this light up and got some cool
points here you guys will all take this
home it's absolutely no big deal and
finally the last thing I'm going to
leave you with is talking about making
your auditing audience jump first thing
that came in mind for this what
is our boy neo jumping over the building
and failing the first time if you make
your audience jump too much in a
presentation they're going to fall under
the fall down what you want to do is you
want your presentation to be a little
hopscotch tell your audience to jump 21
22 23 and four to five to six and seven
you're guiding their mind throughout the
presentation all right so like I said
before we have a bunch of good resources
and goodies for you I put the snapchat
logo because you can actually scan a QR
code or snapchat I didn't know that I
know you all snapchat so it's all good
and there's a URL up there if you guys
want it all the resources thank you very
much